privacy is a top priority for any
company handling user data and these
days that's just about every company
as data policy and regulation continue
the rapid evolution
privacy engineers have emerged to play a
crucial role in taking these laws and
guidelines and putting them into
practice
which is why udacity is excited to
introduce the privacy engineer
nanodegree program
in the privacy engineer nanodegree
program
students will act as both a technologist
and a compliance officer to reduce
privacy risks at every stage of the
product development lifecycle from
ideation through product launch and
beyond
the program will cover the principles
and tools of data protection in the
software world how to manage compliance
at an organizational level and much more
you'll learn from instructors with
significant experience in the cyber
security and privacy industries and
complete two distinct projects that
demonstrate you have the skills required
to contribute on the job right away
enroll today in udacity's privacy
engineer nanodegree program and be in
demand
[Music]
you